what's up guys if you're not subscribed
Please Subscribe also please smash that
like button on the video and enjoy the
show so that's a model prediction now
String Theory the question is can it
predict anything you're bringing you're
doing my job for me I love it you're
great well I've learned a lot from you
you've actually helped me grow the into
the impossible podcast you know 100,000
subscribers in less than a year yeah
yeah your channel is still by by the way
I will have all your links in our
description your channel in my opinion
is still massively underrated I mean the
people you're getting there yeah I mean
you're so connected in the field but
it's it's incredible yeah it's been you
know they say like when you get to the
top of the mountain where you're closer
to than I am or you know someone like
Joe or something like Joe Rogan who's
who's a wonderful I call him you know
the the biggest mench in the business
he's influenced so many of us right and
uh he gives us kind of a Target to
Aspire to yeah and when I was on the
podcast with him I asked him like what
are your goal because I was like you're
always asking everybody else like what
are your goals in the podcast like what
do you want to do and where is your kind
of promised land for where you want to
go and he was just like I have this life
that's like a Life by design that allows
me to not necessarily have freedom to do
anything although he does I mean he owns
a comedy story he probably flies private
he does whatever but he has freedom from
he doesn't have a boss I mean he
advertises stuff that he makes like it's
not like oh well like U I don't know who
your advertisers I saw some some powders
out there I'm like I don't know if I
should mention them or not don't mention
them yet I mention them okay fine uh but
there's some delicious stuff out there
um and uh you know but like when I have
an Advertiser have to do it and then the
sponsor comes back oh you misplaced the
you know kind of product placement or my
favorite is you were supposed to log in
to this link that you know is where
you're or people are going to access I'm
like the content's still there like why
do I have to log in and they're like
well someone might see that it's like
Brian keading or or not Brian keing it's
just like new user oh my God so I'm like
thanks now I have a boss this is what
Ari has to do for you you should tell
him to take care of I know I love AR
hopefully we'll see him um so but the
bottom line is when when you have
something that makes predictions more
powerful a scientific theory is the more
predictions it can make and the more
retrodictions it can explain in other
words it can explain things that used to
happen you ask me about gravity so will
we ever know that gravity has been o
overturned or we were wrong I suspect no
and the reason is because we know it's
already wrong it's wrong in in a certain
sense when we say that something is a
scientific fact let's say I say Do you
believe the Earth is round yes okay well
you're totally wrong you know if I say
to you is the earth flat you'll say no
you also be you'll you'll be right if
you say no right but we have proven that
though because it's here we we okay so
the earth now I'm going to go into
Professor mode okay this is my wife
loves this uh so the Earth is not a
perfect sphere right it has some
spherical property it's actually pretty
oblate it has it has properties like a
pair but it's not flat it's not flat so
if you said it's flat you're wrong and
if you say it's a sphere you're wrong
but as Isaac azimov said you're less
wrong if you say it's a sphere than if
it's a flat if you said it was perfectly
flat now what does that imply that means
that there would be some perfect there
is some perfect description and even if
I said it's pearshaped I'm also wrong
but it's getting closer and closer to
the scientific truth science is not
about saying provable facts again we
can't prove that fat that the Earth is a
prolate spheroid with these spherical
harmonic contributions that distortions
at this you know 0 one% level the way
that I can prove 2 plus 2 equals 4 even
though that'll take 400 pages of
abstract mathematics to prove that
simple sounding statement you can't say
oh you have one finger you got no no no
that's not what we're talking about the
actual mathematics behind proving 2 plus
2al four is significantly Advanced it's
not it's not basic mathematics like I
teached you to a you know 5-year-old but
there is no such thing as proving
physically that the Earth is a sphere or
a pair or whatever shape you want a
donut there is no way to prove that
there scientifically all we can do is
say something is wrong but what you
should do is say things that are
accurate as much as you can with
Precision so let me talk about the
difference between accuracy and
precision if I say you weigh less than
1,000 pounds I mean you've been going to
the gym you look pretty pretty pretty
pretty diesel buddy but um but you
definitely do that's accurate is it
precise doesn't tell you anything
absolutely correct it is not precise so
you want to have accuracy and precision
so I want to say the Earth is not a
sphere then I have to add some terms to
it that makes it more precise but it's
still not perfectly accurate so you want
to try to convert now my question and I
think what Eric you know complains about
people like mitaku is that say something
akin to you weigh less than 1,000 PBS
and they'll say isn't this great we now
have a scientifically testable you know
fact that okay so I actually had
literally one of the fathers of modern
String Theory his name is Camron vafa
he's a brilliant man a wonderful mench
of a guy up at up at Harvard and he was
on my podcast and he said no Brian it's
not true that string theory doesn't make
any predictions he basically said no
string theory predicts the mass of the
electron and I was like I didn't know
that that's kind of news to me what is
it what's the pred first of all it's not
a prediction it's a retrod we already
have the measurement so now he's saying
where does it come from purely
mathematically within the confines of of
the limitations of strength the he said
yes we have limits on it I said
obviously you're not going to say it's
exactly you know 10 to the minus 28 pump
with 65 decimal places behind the 28 no
no but he said it's greater than
effectively it would be like saying
you're weigh between 1 kilogram you and
10 to the 30th kilogram except it's put
a negative sign wide yeah but look what
could what could those numbers be Julian
what could possibly be pick a number
what what what is the range of those
exponents it could be anything from
negative Infinity to positive Infinity
yeah numbers we can't concept at all
exactly but not only that we can't
concept so actually it's a very accurate
thing within the broad range of all it
could be from negative Infinity to
positive Infinity right so it's actually
very accurate right just like me saying
like you between um zero pounds and
infinity pounds okay so a very I put a
th000 kilog rather uh that's very
acccurate compared to what that could be
the SP so that's why I think people like
Eric and people like me to be honest I
won't speak for Eric but but for me it
get frustrated because um when we talk
when we hear other theorists talk about
this I get very upset uh because I think
that their job is is very envious they
get to literally think they don't they
don't necessarily have to travel to
Chile and deal with um you know dumping
concrete on in the wrong place getting
electri you think it was hard to set up
this beautiful Studio imagine doing that
177,000 ft wearing a hard hat oxygen
mask steel toed boots wearing a
lifesaving vest in case you fall over
and die getting checked for all sorts of
high altitude sickness and diseases
having to pass a physical ex you know
versus sitting in your office yeah
sitting in your office and you know
living the life of the mind now when you
ask those people when I ask Saina Hassen
Felder or I ask um Steven Wolfram and I
say well what do you think about Eric's
Theory or what do you think about uh um
you know Steven's Theory to to sabinaa
Hassen Phil and they'll say oh I don't
have time you don't have time like what
else are you working on I mean she's got
a thriving YouTube channel and she's
she's you know that's great that's her
job now and she she is doing research
and and she's to be commended for it but
she's not a professor she's not doing
even is neither is Stephen wlfr he's not
a professor I mean he ears a business
and he's very good at what he does but
to say I don't have time all I have time
for is to look at my own uh Theory and
and kind of verify that like me saying
I'm going to ignore these other
experiments that actually saying Brian
keing you saw dust you claimed to see
the origin of the universe you saw dust
you're a fraud you're a charlatan you're
a if I just did that and I didn't listen
to the critics that would be pathetic
and and yet I do feel like there's an
unwillingness for these theorist to
spend CLE refering to your bicep that's
the bicep exper okay thank you for
watching the video guys please hit that
subscribe button and check out this
clip's full podcast Episode by clicking
here or in the description below